you might think the process that
determines how much you pay for
something is pretty straightforward and
it often is for example here's the
supply chain for a beverage you might
buy at the drugstore say a Pepsi Pepsi
Co manufactures the soda and sends it to
a retailer who sells it to a customer a
customer pays the retailer and the
retailer pays PepsiCo symbol right well
that is not the case for the products
behind the pharmacy counter the drugs
here's a typical supply chain for
prescription drugs it looks really
different that's because the way that
drugs are priced is not at all a
straightforward process experts in
politicians argue that the very
complexity of this chain is part of our
drug prices have grown so high for
customers everyone involved in the
broken system the drug makers insurance
companies distributors pharmacy benefit
managers and many others contribute to
the problem to understand this debate
first you should understand the flow of
drugs and money within this chain let's
start here with the pharmaceutical
companies they're the ones who develop a
drug and set a price known as the list
price this isn't as straightforward as
it might look which we'll explain in a
moment next you have the wholesalers who
transport the drugs and sell them to the
pharmacies the patient pays the copay
and the pharmacy sends out a bill that
gets paid by the insurance company
that's simple enough but we're missing a
link the link that manages this
transaction and adds a lot of complexity
to the chain meet the pharmacy benefit
managers or PBMs they're who the drug
companies and some politicians are
talking about when they refer to
middlemen they work for insurance
companies big employers and government
agencies and a big part of their job is
to bring down the cost of drugs for
their employers they do this by
negotiating with pharmaceutical
companies for rebates yep for many of
the drugs a pharmaceutical
company sells it pays a rebate to the
PBM the PBM sometimes pockets a portion
of the rebate and passes another portion
on to the insurance company or employer
why the pharmaceutical company pays
these rebates is the source of a lot of
controversy what happens is the drug
company gets moved up on something
called a formulary so what's a formulary
it's the list of drugs that the
insurance company covers and it's
grouped in tiers
each tier represents what portion of the
list price the patient pays and what
portion of the list price the insurance
company pays the highest here in the
formulary is the lowest copay for the
patient and the lowest here is the
highest copay for the patient when the
pharmaceutical company pays a higher
rebate the PBM will move the drug up on
the formulary pharmaceutical companies
want high placement on the formulary
that's because patients are more likely
to take the drug that's most affordable
and that usually means higher sales for
the pharmaceutical company if a patient
wants to take a drug that's lower down
on the formulary or not on it at all
they have to pay higher co-pays or even
the full list price of the drug if this
seems confusing that's because it is
let's take another walk through that
transaction this time with an example
say a hypothetical drug costs $100 a PBM
negotiates a $50 rebate ten dollars of
which they pocket and $40 of which they
pass on to the insurance company or
employer in return for that rebate the
PBM moves the drug to a better spot on
the formulary making it cheaper for the
patient to buy the drug this transaction
is important because the pharmaceutical
companies say it's a big reason they
keep raising the price of drugs
you've probably seen a chart like this
before
it's the rise in the price of a drug in
the u.s. in this case Humalog according
to its maker Eli Lilly the
pharmaceutical companies say they have
to raise less prices to protect their
sales and profits from the demands of
these higher rebates here's the CEO of
the pharmaceutical company Merck at a
hearing on drug prices if you bring a
product to the market with a low list
price in this system you get punished
financially and you get no uptake
because everyone in the supply chain
makes money as a result of a higher list
price and here's that Humalog chart
again this time with the net price or
the average revenue that Eli Lilly says
they take in under this system for their
part the PBM say the drug companies
don't have to raise prices to boost
their bottom lines and that rebates
reduce the cost of drugs not inflates
them they say rebates reduce the real
cost of prescription drugs because they
lower the price that insurance companies
pay that helps the insurers lower the
premiums that the patients have to pay
for their plans
here's darica rice an executive vice
president at CVS Caremark one of the
pharmacy benefit managers our job is to
work with the employers unions and
government programs we serve to ensure
that when their members get to the
pharmacy counter they get the medicines
that they need at the lowest possible
cost so what does all of this mean for
the patient back at the pharmacy counter
at the heart of all this is that what
the patient pays is often based on the
list price not the price the insurance
company is responsible for after the
rebates and patients who don't have
insurance or coinsurance or who have
really high deductibles sometimes pay
the entire list price it's important to
know that the details surrounding
rebates are shrouded in mystery
pharmaceutical companies and PBMs don't
release their rebate data saying it's
proprietary but it's clear that
different people and
different insurance companies pay
different prices for the same drugs as
you can see the way that prices work
behind the counter is totally different
from how they work in front
[Music]